el sistema reproductor femenino incluye
la vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
durante el sexo vaginal entre un hombre
y una mujer el semen sale del pene del
hombre y entra en la vagina de la mujer
en un proceso denominado eyaculación
el semen contiene decenas de millones de
espermatozoides en la vagina los
espermatozoides pueden pasar a través
del cuello uterino del útero y de las
trompas de falopio para fertilizar un
óvulo del ovario de la mujer
la fertilización del óvulo representa el
inicio del desarrollo del ser humano
un capuchón cervical es un método de
control de natalidad o anticonceptivo es
un dispositivo temporal y reutilizable
que las mujeres pueden usar para evitar
el embarazo el capuchón cervical está
fabricado con caucho flexible
y tiene la forma de un gorro de marinero
tiene una cúpula con una cinta de
extracción en la parte superior
el borde que rodea la cúpula tiene un
lado corto
y otro largo
los capuchones cervicales deben
utilizarse con una sustancia que mata a
los espermatozoides denominada
espermicida para aumentar su eficacia
la mujer debe introducir el capuchón
cervical en la vagina antes de tener
relaciones sexuales para evitar un
embarazo
la cúpula del capuchón cervical cubre el
cuello uterino lo que evita que los
espermatozoides en el semen del hombre
entren en el útero
él espermicida aplicado el capuchón mata
a los espermatozoides que entran en
contacto con él
existen algunos detalles que deben
recordarse antes de utilizar un capuchón
cervical no utilice el capuchón cervical
entre 8 y 10 semanas luego de dar a luz
o si tuvo un aborto espontáneo o un
aborto en un periodo de seis semanas
dado que el cuello uterino es más grande
en estos períodos es más fácil quedar
embarazada utilizando un capuchón
cervical no utiliza un capuchón cervical
en los siguientes casos durante el
periodo menstrual ya que puede bloquear
el drenaje normal de la sangre del útero
si tiene una infección u otra afección
médica que afecte el útero el cuello
uterino o la vagina
si el capuchón está roto o dañado
para utilizar un capuchón cervical lave
sus manos y retírelo de su envase
aplique un cuarto de cucharadita de
espermicida dentro de la cúpula hasta e
incluyendo el borde
aplique media cucharadita adicional de
es permitida en la ranura entre la parte
exterior de la cúpula y el borde
luego elija una posición para empezar a
introducir el capuchón puede acostarse
con las rodillas dobladas agacharse con
ambos pies en el suelo o pararse con un
pie apoyado sobre una silla
introduzca los dedos índice y medio
dentro de la vagina hasta encontrar el
cuello uterino
de esa forma sabrá dónde colocar el
capuchón cervical
luego apriete el capuchón cervical con
la cúpula orientada en dirección opuesta
a la vagina
a continuación deslice el capuchón en la
vagina y deje que el lado largo del
borde entre primero con uno o dos dedos
deslice lo tan lejos como sea posible en
la vagina revise con los dedos para
constatar que el capuchón toca y cubre
completamente el cuello uterino
puede dejarlo en la vagina hasta 48
horas
antes de extraer el capuchón cervical
espere 6 horas después de la última vez
que tuvo relaciones sexuales
para extraerlo agáchese con ambos pies
en el suelo introduzca un dedo en la
vagina para buscar la cinta que cubre la
cúpula del capuchón cervical
empuje suavemente la cúpula con la punta
del dedo para hacerle un mullido y
romper el accesorio de succión al cuello
uterino
luego enganche el dedo en la cinta y
jale la lenta y delicadamente
tras extraer el capuchón cervical lávelo
con agua y jabón y deja que se seque al
aire el capuchón cervical es más eficaz
en evitar el embarazo en mujeres que
nunca han estado embarazadas ni han
tenido un parto vaginal
los capuchones cervicales tienen una
eficacia del 96 por ciento para evitar
el embarazo si se utilizan correctamente
cada vez que una mujer tiene relaciones
sexuales los capuchones cervicales
tienen una eficacia aproximada del 92
por ciento si se utilizan de forma
habitual es decir que no siempre se los
utiliza o no se los utiliza
correctamente todas las veces que una
mujer tiene relaciones sexuales